Snoop Dogg is probably one of the
most memorable rappers out there
and has been making music and
movies since the early 90's.
So in the first part of today's lesson
we're going to cover a fragment of his first
solo single "Who Am I, What's My Name?" and
then we'll take a look at some of his big hits
from the 90's and also more recent ones.
Are you ready? Let's jump straight in!
By the way, in case you're new here, we help
you to learn fast English without getting lost,
without missing the jokes and without subtitles.
Just like this fan, who says that not only
has he improved his fluency but
he now understands British and
American accents thanks to our channel.
So don't forget to hit that Subscribe
button and the Bell down below, so that
you don't miss any of our new lessons!
Do you struggle to understand
fast speaking natives?
Then I highly recommend our
Fluent with Friends Course.
In this 48-week course you will learn
with the first two seasons of Friends.
You'll receive PDF power lessons every week,
vocabulary memorization software, access to our
Fluency Circle Global Community and so much more.
And the best part is you can try it right
now for FREE with our 3-Part Masterclass.
All you have to do is click up here or down
in the description box below to learn more and
sign up now. We look forward to seeing you there!
If you enjoy learning English with songs then
I highly recommend you check out this playlist.
You'll find a great variety of artists
to choose from and you can click up
here or down in the description box
below to choose your next lesson.